male actors the cornerstone of American
cinema don't get enough credit don't get
enough credit white male actors
especially they're all underrated but
today we're gonna watch for
watchmojo.com the top ten underrated
male actors this is top reward to your
request from Cameron French you sexy son
of a bastard
John is one of the most underrated male
actors you'll ever see hmm likewise have
you seen this guy Red Rover
civil defense let's do this short film
anthology film you're in something
that's right I've been things all the
creatures were stirring Jonah Joker
sketch let's watch the bond of easy yeah
Ron Perelman yeah yeah it's so - I'd say
such a welcome to watchmojo.com and
today we're counting down our picks for
the top 10 underrated male actors for
this list we're looking at those pop
idols who we also Harbor oh yeah these
are the actors we easily read this list
is from 2014
by the way so we'll see if any of them
haven't gone I'm more popular in my time
acting job har but we want to see them
sniff out from the shadows and directly
into the limelight Oh
the legend is lacking not quite the God
the stories made you out but he's the
villain hates dragon
not to be confused with Nicole Kidman's
country singing husband Keith Urban
this new xenotransplantation saga
industry for over three plays dizziness
fatal flaws for emotion she feels his
Hollywood debut aboard the ghost ship oh
he's added many heavy hitting
blockbusters to his resume including an
American he's doing pretty good now man
to the small screen with a starring role
in the futuristic primetime hits
almost-humans I'm gonna go through every
piece my hand
he's like Australia more on Dan only two
things feel good in the junk that's
jerking off and thinking about all that
[ __ ] you're gonna do when you get out we
may be most familiar with it was good at
home to be covered in red makeup and
donning sawed-off nothing gonna do when
I could I can't but this cool cats been
in the game since before some of us were
late David Harper is my the eyes of a
man they help over 30 years of acting
work my god
it's tender tough-guy persona makes him
perfect for playing a monster who a
biker with a heart of gold and
everything in between
[Music]
drive to number eight Colin Farrell hair
we tried all right starting a lot of
crap he's come back around kinds of
Grindelwald his fair share of bombs the
carol has remained just a little Hotel
recap or perhaps it's because he shines
more in dark indie comedy than he does
in huge blockbusters so Horrible Bosses
he saw Stephanie not now or did
monetized this videos results that was
shot together with your dad no name see
her dad died episode wonder big-screen
potential if we've learned anything from
his time on be lucky billion he's got
like no silver screen they aren't
exactly enough to complement this use
perspective megastar status this day
evidenced by his cultivate work on
Firefly maybe I'm not a fancy gentleman
like you with your very fine hat
business in the meantime at least we get
to enjoy watching him run around solving
crimes on network TV yeah bondage my
safe word is Apple's number six James
McAvoy
for this Scottish star having an affair
with a dictators wife or curving a
bullet away from Angelina Jolie's face
are both way safer to do on the big
screen man in real life yes they'll also
put you on Hollywood's radar it only
mildly he has an HBO show now a UK
series shameless I'm gonna second chance
maybe good impression like he was in
shameless the UK one I think his
appearance in The Chronicles of Narnia
truly brought him he's famous now
Professor X they chapter two he's still
number five he earned praise for his
work as the ship doctor master you'll
meet him with good choice too portrayed
the devoutly Catholic out by now not to
kill in Logans as well wonderful English
dad became the go-to when it comes to
voicing artificial intelligence systems
for billionaire Playboy's with suits
made of iron
maybe now what about women-friendly
Giovanni Ribisi he just had this big
smile on his face and he was waving
because he was always happiest when he
was on his stilts he's been in so many
films over the years that your eyes may
have grown up seeing him avatar never
the bride he's enjoyed steady work for
almost 20 years appearing in a number of
big-name films after breaking through to
the big time on friends yeah was that
really what broken well he did get to
start as a fraudulent stockbroker back
in 2000 most of his roles have been
supporting but that doesn't mean we
don't see him shiny Chris I got arrested
last night whoa arrested me I can always
come in the bends voices number three
Eric Bana oh he's a superstar down this
walk gentleman from Down Under
seems to be skilled at landing roles
opposite some really attractive people
that's a talent in itself yeah it
probably helps when you're also
good-looking sorry she Ronin Hanuman
Chris Pine but promised myself virtually
and although baños starred in a couple
of big budget action flicks he's got
some serious comedic chops that we've
only seen glimpses up trip that shot me
birds I know movie when I realize I hate
his and that's the only movie I like
camera Frenchified really have said I
mean making its way up to the Oscar
podium at some point back home I'll be
working some nowhere job yeah it's
almost six years guess what Andy Serkis
was in procedure for God all about that
I don't think I made the connection of
this process jean reno guys Pink Panther
Godzilla
99 yeah that's it so what about Richard
Jenkins there but I'm doing everything
possible to restore profitability to
this company the company that I know who
you stay there jelly
[Music]
he has been recognized he let us know
that we need to be seeing more of him by
plane an astronaut stranded on the moon
and given his exceptional performance we
couldn't oh you know who should be on
here Sam Jackson for more entertaining
top 10s published oh my god I use so
much there's so many other rated men
okay Martin frequently it's kind of
underrated we gave him a shot franchise
opportunity guys you prompt you probably
know his name do i plays Looking Glass
and watchman oh it's him Blake Nelson
yeah his name so brother Tim Blake
Nelson I think he is one of the most
underrated actors ever that's a great
call
man I am blanking on names right now Tom
Holland
no tobey maguire nigh a chance Delroy
Lindo sure he'd be on there went on the
bad guy in rogue one he placed me on The
Pines
0:01 Mendelssohn man acid yeah 2014 so
it's pretty fascinating to see who has
who is remain the one that stood out to
me the most I haven't seen Eric Bana and
so long
he was in something and that goes I
thought bana would be famous like really
famous by now yeah I thought he would be
like a like an elder statesman of acting
at this point because he's a cooler man
Karl Urban really has a fan base now
though his name might not be as a list
celebrity as one might hope dread I
think really gained him a cult following
but the boys he's a scene stealer in
that series man he is so good no boys oh
my goodness and I watched Pete's dragon
for the first time and he's the bad guy
in it yes you really yeah damn it's not
very good character oh I found the one
bad boy Carl Cooper for that's why it's
the character the way it's written I
first saw him in Bourne Supremacy
that's right Evo's bought him Richard
Jenkins and I said I'm overreacting to
it yeah I don't think Richard Jenkins
would be a good one to add to this list
there's a lot of actors who we see as a
lot of main supporting characters like
they're the best supporting characters
you can get yeah people who like make a
career out of being supporting character
Ron Perlman is an actor who you know
they're because of his look and his
overall cadence I get why he's typecast
in the certain roles he's in I like his
some of his weaker characters I can
drive
he's like under Albert Brooks yeah he
wants to be more respected but clearly
he feels cheated in life you know so I'm
more drawn to Ron Perlman now when he
does those kind of roles though I'm so
used to seeing him play like top dog
tough guy you know but he's also really
funny and I think he deserves a lot of
credit for how funny he is yeah
definitely and it does make you in this
list appreciate that he did get to lead
at least you know to Hellboy films even
though he's under the makeup like he did
get that starring opportunity I think
Colin Farrell's fine others some people
names hero people will have
no idea who they are but I think
everyone knows come on Alan Farrell's a
star yeah everyone knows his name we
often overlook him in terms of how
amazing even today we overlook how
amazing a curious because of the big
movie scene he's in he never really gets
a chance to truly shine because of the
SWAT era and the sex was keeping him
from the utmost respect yeah but more so
than ever like the in the recent portion
of his career especially I feel like
he's really been turning out some great
work he's respected man he's respected
Nathan Fillion called following type of
actor he's hysterical sexy he's one of
those guys who like even if he's not the
most mainstream actor he's doing fine he
worries so much Paul Bettany might have
a shot though with Wanda vision coming
out he might be able to finally
skyrocket the Paul Bettany name yeah
he's been looking for superstardom for a
long time and I think this is finally
gonna gonna clinch it for him he married
Jennifer Connelly now that didn't work
out that there were his famous no I just
made everyone go he got Derrick only I
don't think he's like really sexy he's
really handsome you know and in person
it's a lot different than you know when
he's at one screen I was really
surprised I'm like Jennifer Connelly
that's something special
she's pretty beautiful and then went it
didn't and then Paul Bettany I was like
sweet oh this way he's really like his
personality he's not an unattractive god
[Music]
dude rubee 0bc
I don't ever wanted to become top tier
famous you know there's a point where
Gary Oldman was like the most under
recognized actor yeah and then he got so
recommended know like oh really pay
attention to Gary Oldman but for the
longest time your Elmen was this
stealthy character accurate a true
chameleon yeah because he was always in
these movies and you're like oh that was
Gary Oldman it was Gary just fully
transformed Ribisi is kind of like I
don't wanna say he's like a real buddy
yeah he's that actor who I would always
wanted to just to stay the character
actor that he is yeah sure he'd like to
be famous as hell but you know I feel
like he's probably got his lane though
and you know it's like the most famous
actors typically aren't as much into
always transforming into characters and
I really always appreciate Giovanni
Ribisi when he shows up cuz he is so
good at characters to the point that
it's sometimes like unsettling like in
Ted like he's so committed even though
that movie is a you know silly comedy
Peter Sarsgaard your sleepy boy where is
he now people yeah was the last thing he
did I wouldn't say he's underrated I
would say that when he was game popular
he was the most overrated thing say
squarely rated now now that the hype has
died down the Sarsgaard hype I know
everyone really likes this guy she just
always rubbed me the wrong way you just
seem like the kind of guy wouldn't like
what I got a see you gotta put that to
the test
I don't even fully get it I liked him in
jarhead but everything else
ITC Jarrah - it's like even if they they
show Kinsey I'm like I hated him in
Kinsey I thought it was awful maybe he's
just one of those guys for you
everybody's got one who'd they just
can't get into their performances it's
just like wake up get some rest
memorize lines Ruffalo woke up just be
tired yeah and then he did spotlight and
he was like really into solving that
case yeah it was so funny I was thought
it was like quiet serious tired guy yeah
that's all you remained Peter Sarsgaard
good job on Green Lantern quite [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah door I know in the minority on that
one Sam Rockwell though I know he's fun
now he's fine with all day like awards
and with the ease of one of those actors
who has truly arrived and everyone's
like he's a terrific actor but also he
can play how many fun character once he
played redemptive racist yeah did we all
gave him a pass we all helped out
Francis McDormand no backlash to his
character not at all like I love this
guy I think he earned it and we should
always support care
I have questions ask me still not being
insanely famous now but I feel like even
people who don't follow movie news and
like deeper cut actors are starting to
know his name now especially because
you've got the Marvel assist I feel like
he's good at straddling the popular but
also the prestige but hey I mean it's
been five years since this list dropped
so it seems about the amount of time
that he has had to really clinch that
extra oomph of I am now in the spotlight
right clench your butt Sam Rockwell
those cheeks not guys well which
underrated male actors do you think
should be on this list
forced Whitaker perhaps ooh Oh Shia
Jackson the guy from John Carr Taylor
Kitsch that's the one you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified when
we got a YouTube video hit the like
button or the dislike button either one
counts Cameron French thanks so much for
requesting this man can't wait to see
you start up your YouTube channel your
blog you are one of the most informative
gentlemen at our patreon page this guy
is always sending me information on
things a lot of times I don't even get
this down low and he'll send it to me
articles could be like read this it's
got the scoops take out 40 minutes from
your day to read this and I go yeah
Cameron fresh nuts never that long I'm
sure he's gonna send me the list of the
actors he finds to be the most
underrated ain't you better you better
send it over as soon as you can do 10
plus honorable mentions I just want to
say thank you for being you hope you
have a Merry Christmas
Nev a sexy Santa girl for you that's for
you yeah I mean I could do it if you
want paint my beard white I would love
to dance for Cameron French drop me like
one of your wanna French girls be Santa
yeah for Cameron French Oh